first thing I am when I was in high
school I did four years of drama 9/11 12
so I have sort of a theatrical metaphor
for the whole of today so here's my
first thing when I think of studying I
think you're rehearsing for like a
performances I like that right so my
first question to you is um I went
backwards so my first question to you is
what's special about studying math okay
studying different subjects they're not
all the same and what you do a little
bit to exercise for me I want you to put
a little piece of paper if you've got
like a space under there right I want
you to write the word mass per circle in
it and then in the space that you have
around that I want you to list our the
other subjects you do at school
okay so you know what's the obvious one
you just had English okay you got
science you've got what else do you do
you do languages you do PE history
geography music what else do you do
alright now here's what I want you to do
and I just want you to list them out
like I have I want you to write them
down in this space but the positions
important that's you in the middle I
just want you think about these subjects
which ones are similar to manners and
which ones are different so if they're
different
write them far away if you feel like
they're similar put them close to me
okay I'll just give you 30 seconds to do
that and then I want to compare the
results that we yeah okay so if you
think it's similar to maths put it close
if you think it's very different put it
far away so here's my question to you
let's let's go through this this English
is it nearer Zafar is it far far let's
put it up in the corner there or in this
one like Midway it's far away it's about
as far away from you okay all right sure
science way we put it pretty close like
really close on sort of
pretty close sobriety yeah is that okay
yeah languages which what languages
other side also faraway languages PE
wispy now outside the box
second Koran so K no yes the people are
put in something else somewhere in the
deal my shabak we don't have consensus
oh that's fine that's curious history
geography magic history press history
okay music far wait
okay let's do visual arts drama together
now outside outside creative before we
cants should be on another whiteboard
okay last one technology which put that
in clothes became no this is interesting
to me so I listen I think we've got a
pre-baked straight view of what the
subjects unlike in fact if I put
engineering as a subject here it'd
probably be in here and you guys have
actually nailed some people like you
know professional education like I need
they actually love these four things
together and they call it stem science
technology engineering and maths okay
it's a theme right now here's the
interesting thing
here's what I'd like to put to you under
the question on how to study right how
to study
I think he's a user he's in my blood for
a game I think that this is actually all
wrong it turns out how to study okay I
think in terms of which ones are closest
to mass I really think it should be
peaking all right now hmm let me try and
justify that to you right sports or
music how many do you play a musical
instrument yeah what yeah what do you
play keyboard yeah
try the triangle yes thank God for
triangle plans okay and was there
another one in the back someone's drums
also protect personally personally I
played the acoustic guitar okay
yeah he's the thing about developing
skill with a musical instrument okay
there is one way and only one way to
develop skill musically okay and that is
to play music to practice it to actually
get out the triangle and you know like
how should I get it how fast like all
these kinds of questions right you could
read about an instrument all you like
and you will not get better please
I think PE in sport is in the same kind
of camp right you want to get good at a
sport you can watch it on TV a lot
you'll get something but you will not
get any better than throwing a dummy
posh right or funny all those kinds of
things right you've got to do them okay
and maths is the same okay
sure that's why I let me let me level
this off that's weighing your mask
losses right yeah far out we have to
adjust they may just do what I can't
work shades chapters after chapter
chapter of exercising that kind of thing
did you notice what they were cold
they're cold
exercises
accident right big is saying to you that
practice is the important thing so let
me get this some dichotomy these two
ideas in your hand skill versus mastery
okay
amateurs versus experts okay we want to
get all of you guys toward this down
this end of the spectrum okay it's good
to have this but this is what really
happens in an exam this is the
difference between people who do I can
examine really do well now there's the
difference between amateurs and experts
when it comes to practical things like
music and PE and maths is the amateurs
they practice something until they can
get it right any like cool I've got it
right we want to next thing right but
experts practice something till they
can't get it wrong do hundreds of times
okay it's why tennis players have those
machines that will just spit ball after
ball make you stand there and work
through the same forearm hit over and
over again okay to develop mastery you
must practice okay